I'm gonna keep you toasty and warm by
this fire my little biscuit hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to destiny rebellion oh yes
let's save please also checkpoint would
be nice okay so I'm here in these frozen
caverns I don't know much about this
world but I know one thing this world is
connected it is full of reflections and
illusions of other worlds not only from
different space but also different time
just like this cave I don't know how
many time travelers if it is into place
before I have to go and find out more I
hope nothing will kill me when I leave
this area oh that would be just the
worst good thing I got tiny bug stem
here to protect me I wonder if it's
gonna be that douche because he looks
kind of like the douchey Deus that you
would expect to do douchey things and
ergo probably gonna kill you large oil
potion large tinderbox potion it's of
pigs paintings of the name of the game
and that's it is there anything else
here that I actually need besides a
billion inanimate objects that are not
tiny box stem that I don't actually need
to worry about and I continually forget
that I actually have oil in my lanterns
that was a big medicine okie dokie one
two three tender boxes and that's it
okay I'm out of here alright moving on
in the next area come with me my little
buddy that's okay I got your back I know
you do little buddy and that's why I
love you with all my I through you but I
didn't mean it how could you you I
almost went off the edge oh I'm so sorry
but that that's a hard voice to do in
Kona
oh okay I shouldn't have looked back
they were obviously chasing me
this looks nice I'll go down here
through there I wasn't expecting that I
was actually expecting oh okay okay so I
could either get tiny box stammer I can
get that sward I'm gonna choose tiny box
sim ooh this is nice
music seems to be skipping a bit can
someone hit the CD Bohai it is zero
gravity in here but why what is the
point of all this am I supposed to jump
up on these floating rocks and then move
forward is that how this is can I do
that I don't think I can do that
whoa okay that hurt I just broke my legs
but that's alright
nice jump there into death can I have
some medicine thank you very much I Tim
all right go me go yeah I got it oh no
no I lost him again oh he'll never see
him again it's alright
Oh still live in your heart time to back
to Tim I think your voice is going a
little bit you may want to get some
lawsuit ins or something like that I
don't know what lozenges are but no way
to set it correctly I don't know okay so
that's two of three zones down and you
guys got to remember we're still only in
chapter 2 here of what I think is four
separate chapters so there's a lot of
game to go through and I'm gonna try to
get through it as expediently as
possible man I gotta say that this is
interesting they put so much work I
can't say that it's exactly polished
this game is by far from super refined
and well crafted but man does it have
heart the creator's just put a lot of
interesting ideas into it and there's
almost too many ideas that are being
crammed into the same delicious box a
tiny box and I don't have any more but
I'm so now okay that's death that is
death instant death I should remember
that all water especially green water is
lava and this is the world
biggest game of the floor is lava and I
need not lost no further
so was supposed to go over this way is
that what I was supposed to do can you
tell me if that was a with otherwise
supposed to do I can't make that jump
there's no way it's impossible I wonder
if I'm not going the correct way I think
I might be breaking the game here a
little bit but I'm alive and that's the
most important part and I'm on the
Technic colored rainbow so one that
Dorothy didn't go on there was a yellow
road yellow brick road and then there
was an LSD brick road if you licked the
road you would go on an adventure unlike
any other if you know it that was one
hell of a splash there I might have been
too much of a splash if you asked me
I've had it up to here with these stupid
splishy-splashy douches okay so that
wasn't like the ice caverns I wasn't
supposed to like that so so okay I'm
sorry is there something of important is
hippo how are you doing I'm just gonna
climb on your head for a little bit
don't mind me using you like that hi I
almost got startled by a fern Oh am i
dead why God that was the biggest bone
spider I've ever seen in my life
bone Durr spider no no that doesn't work
at all oh damn it I'm all the way back
here wait a minute was there another
path over this way that I could have
gone looks like some stepping stones
here whoo whoa whoa okay still alive
come on I keep getting stuck on geometry
a lot of ambitions here oh why was that
the super jumpy rock what was that made
out of trampolines they wear of demons
and chupacabras was that what that were
how's the chupacabra
why was that chupacabra spider Frank
Tanqueray can this not throw me into the
Oblivion no you were about to and then
you almost did but I didn't let you so
why why why I can make these jumps why
would you tempt me with a jump that is
obviously not to my better stop that I
know I've already been here you don't
need to be doing the Humpty Humpty that
was the music not Humpty Humpty anything
god I keep getting stuck on every damn I
thought that was gonna be instant death
but luckily it was not okay so I do not
need to go that way where there is a
chupacabra
oh I thought it was gonna crash there
for a second just an extremely long
saving process summon critters whoa that
is messed up bro
Oh what is going on there
sorry I was doing a sweetie oh oh that's
what I summon okay okay I don't
appreciate the cut of your jib here
okay summon critters what does that mean
it's dangerous in here dangerous to go
alone take this
well thanks old man by the way have you
seen the new star bomb music video over
on egoraptor channel god that is a good
music video that was my favorite song of
a star bond album
no I'm dead no it's a troop of cavalry
anyway if you haven't seen or if you
haven't heard of star bomb yet go over
to egoraptor channel he's one of my
favorite youtubers and he's fantastic
animator you probably all know him
already you never mind Who am I saying
that you don't know him but if you don't
go check him out star bomb is their
musical venture that he did with ninja
sex party and they are friggin awesome
also game grumps that's who that is but
anyway it's cool
okay so I gotta try to find a way around
the super Gabba
but he's being a bit of a ding dong damn
douche hello other hippo what's going on
I came oh oh hi
bye where you running off to where are
you running off to pop bits of his blood
went on my face and he is bloated right
in front of me I didn't see anything
actually but I mean I'm just assuming
that's what happened oh okay yes blow my
god well this just got a new level of
disturbing I don't know what's going on
here you all f off oh there's a guy in
here god damn it there's a lot of things
that kill you in here oh my god it's so
brutal anyway what was they saying oh
yeah star bomb star bombs an album that
they made it's actually a musical entry
and he's really cool because all music
video or music game parodies what is
this piddly ass dagger
what is this piddly ass sword what is
this tiny two-edged sword douche no I
don't like him he's not he's not a
colorful character he's not anyone that
I care about he is stupid and I hate him
tiny edged sword wherever I didn't even
have a clever name room 4
- stupid okay this is interesting sand
right there mortal do you even know
where you are and what you're trying to
do you probably don't but let me explain
did you ever believe in the principle of
coincidence you know what there's no
coincidence you and other lower beings
like humans animal monsters and even
bacteria we're always under control
under my control to be more accurate
yeah that's right you've never had a
choice nobody had it was me who was
always pulling the strings I know you
probably don't believe me okay let me
prove it you will try to reach the end
of the quarter but you never will
because I decided not to you claim to a
free will but it's very free will it's
mine
read the notes from Harlequin an
aristocrat find out more hurry
we have a meeting of the cattle today
dr. Miller me I'm gonna call you smitty
werben jaegerman jensen because that
name is unpronounceable and I can
actually pronounce smitty werben
jaegerman jensen so that's really weird
nygma Jensen a bit of a douche well the
prove you wrong I'm gonna make you do
this into the tunnel and you're gonna do
Dan think about it because you dick
so as you Fu in the a and have a lovely
day oh I'm blinking blinking out I'm
fading out and I'm okay kinda it's not
possible this is crazy what's crazy
what's crazy bro can I move yet oh I can
move okay
okay you're a bit of a douche oh hey the
stars in the sky my mental state is
deteriorating let me have a cigarette
apparently Boop and I'm all better now
okay I need to hurry this caliber help
me Excalibur
oh that didn't do jack doodlee but it
stunned him I guess that's good enough
wait a minute I smell secret item around
here what was the other secret item that
I needed a seed of darkness this place
looks like it might hide a seed of
darkness ah that's what they'd want me
to do to rush straight for the thing if
I look around I find exactly nothing
which is exactly what they want to be
not to find so if I don't find anything
that I actually need I'm actually gonna
find what I do I don't know where the
seed of darkness I probably already
missed it
what spooky stomp was not just Olivia
was the vision strengthens was that
talking about where I just was that
would have been useful as I was going
into it
you understand that please you
understand that right you understand
that that was chapter 3 oh yeah that was
chapter 3 I forgot about that
I apologize everyone I thought that I
wasn't
that means this game business close
isn't as far from the end as I
previously anticipated chapter 4
lazarre's quest might be the last
chapter I have no idea but anyway let's
continue oh yeah Lazare doesn't have
anything Hoos are only as monster claw
tool of destruction
well that human was a bit of a douche
nah those are needs a better voice well
guy got human with a bit of a douche but
hopefully he will go get eaten by
another monster boos not one of my prime
or maybe one of my monster brethren that
for some reason hey well hopefully it
makes it divided but only if he doesn't
get to meet his little friend tiny box
Tim that I only just realized that he
had a friend right now but am I'm I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna candy do that
that would get really really really
annoying if I continued that for the
entirety of lazarre's quest which is the
entirety of chapter 4 not anyway I think
I think this is a good point to stop
I'll continue this so that lazarre's
quest should be in one
as opposed to being split in the middle
it's all Ewan thank you all so much for
watching I really really really really
am enjoying this custom story there's so
much happening it's moving forward very
quickly and officially and let yet
there's lots of stuff that's happening
so it's great so thank you all so much
for watching click the end of days
before videos it I've done yes always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]